In this video you're gonna explore ChatGPT agent mode.
This came out and basically it allows you
to combine computer use so ChatGPT can spin up a computer
and then it can do operations on that.
It also has access to a browser so you can technically go
and tell it to autonomously do some web search
or some manual data entry and if you give it
some of the right logins it can do work on your behalf.
Let's have a look at how you can access this
inside of ChatGPT.
So go to chatgpt.com and what you'll need to do
is click on the plus symbol and then turn on agent mode.
Now you can see when you turn on agent mode
you have a certain number of credits.
In my case I've got 34 that remain
and that will be reset on August the 23rd.
So you get a certain amount of credits each month
and then once you turn on agent mode
it actually has a bunch of recommendations
that you can see here.
For example we could create a presentation
so we could do develop a go to mark strategy
for robotic pet launch.
So I'm gonna click that, I'm gonna click
and hit enter on this and then what's gonna happen
behind the scenes is that ChatGPT is gonna set up
its own desktop and that desktop is essentially
a Linux machine that lives on the cloud
and then because of that it can access
to things like Python using a browser.
Also as you can see here give you a live preview
of what ChatGPT is doing in the flow.
So you can see it's doing some searching,
it's then going to do a reading mode
and if you look on the bottom of this
we can actually scroll back and you can see
specifically what different bits the agent decided to take
and that's called a trajectory.
So what trajectory did the agent take?
Now interestingly go to the triple dots,
click on that and you'll see there's three things
here at the moment.
You can see the activities, it gives you a breakdown
of what this specific version has worked on.
That's quite useful to see how often it's searching,
how often it's reviewing.
If we go and do stop then obviously that will stop
the autonomous agent and the other thing
that we can do is we can take over the browser.
Now I'm gonna show you one that I did earlier
so let me go and show you that.
So I've got a broadband affordability analysis
and you can see that basically it went and worked
for 17 minutes and actually built a bunch of slides
and you can see it going and working on the terminal here
and doing lots of code and generating kind of
different types of visualizations and it worked
and then it actually created a presentation
like a download this as a PDF.
So again this is the kind of thing that you get
when you can use chatgbt to generate presentations
and you can see this is what it generated
on different types of broadband and the monthly cost
and all that kind of stuff.
That's what a report looks like when they're finished
now obviously if we go to the go to market strategy
you can see that chatgbt is working
and it's gonna take a while so now it's actually
in the machine and it's running lots of different
types of commands so that's quite useful for seeing
what's happening on the activity view
and obviously if you want you can look
at the desktop view as well.
Great so we've gone through,
I've shown you a report at the end
and obviously we could wait until this report's done
but it's gonna roughly produce some kind of PowerPoint.
The key insight I want you to take away from this
is that you could use this for anything
and we could go a step further and we could not only
use web search and Microsoft Excel and Microsoft PowerPoint
but we can also give chatgbt agent access
to our own websites so if I go and create a new chat
and then we'll go back and we'll go into agent mode
and then what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna click,
I'm actually gonna just not use the suggestion
so I'm gonna say I want to spin up a virtual VM
and I will log into a website.
And what I'm gonna show you is this other feature
of agent mode that we haven't seen yet.
Right to go into the triple dots, click take over browser
and then you can control the browser.
So I can go in here, I can sign into x.com
and if you've already signed in on your chatgbt account
then it should have access to that.
So you can see here I actually have access to this
and we can go and like this post.
So I've signed in with my accounts,
obviously you could sign into anything you want here,
you could go to Facebook, what have you.
That's the power of this is you just sign in
and then it's gonna remember you.
Click on the bottom right, finish controlling.
Then we can say I want you to create three posts
on x.com saying hello world from chatgbt agent mode.
Okay, so here's the powerful thing.
Now it's able to use logins that you've previously provided
and you can basically have that so it can do some work.
So it's decided that that page is Facebook.com
but you can now see if it's gone to x.com
and we can actually see it's gonna go up here
and it's gonna compose.
You will see that it asks you shall I click to publish it
and we'll say continue.
So sometimes it will ask for approval
which is absolutely fine.
We could probably be more specific with the prompt
like if you have to do anything then don't worry about it
and essentially yeah like you can see here
shall I click to publish it and there you go.
So now it's working and the second post is here
and again yeah you can rate these responses.
We can click to continue.
I'll say continue and post without permission.
Let's see if it does that
or whether it actually needs permission.
So I'm gonna just tell it continue
and post without permission.
So let's see, let's have a look.
Yeah, so you can see without further confirmation
prevents yeah so would you like to modify it?
So yeah, yeah modify it and make it unique
for three messages.
But we'll do five messages then and don't ask, just do.
So we're just gonna use some prompting techniques
to specifically lock it in and just tell it
it's absolutely fine, go do the work.
And that'd be the type of thing
that you'll put at the initial prompt
when you're doing whatever task you need to do.
It's just telling it don't ask for permission
or just do the work.
Now obviously you've got to be very careful with that
because you're giving a lot more agency
and you're giving a lot of delegation to agents
but just be aware that you can often open AI
will respect your prompts if you're saying
just do the work.
So I'm gonna go and open a fresh tab
and have a look on x.com and let's see what we've got.
So we've got one, we've got two, how are we doing?
So it says that it's thinking, it says it's thinking.
So here you go, so society is gonna modify these,
it's clicking send so you can see here.
So now I'm gonna do that
and then we're, what are we doing here?
So you've got a bunch of these, hello world, hello world.
Let's see, I'm sending the message
hello world from chatgbt, post two.
Here you go, so post three of five
and then it's clicking post and there we go.
So we've got our third message from chatgbt.
The agent mode, the agent model is now working.
So here you go.
So we learned about the fact that you could use agent mode
to build PowerPoints or presentations,
it has complete access to a virtual machine.
You've learned about how to add in additional types
of websites by using that takeover browser
and you've also learned about how to do
some clever prompt engineering techniques
so that we don't have to keep clicking
that continue button.
All right, the final thing I just wanna say on this
is you can also schedule these
and you can say how often you want them to come
and you can give a range of instructions
and you can tell it when to repeat as well.
So scheduling is also possible
and I will see you in the next one.